when it comes to creating a viral video
there's certain ingredients
that you should have inside of your
video and here at think we are youtube
scientists youtube chefs and we're
always in the kitchen
cooking up some new videos and on
today's
think marketing live we are actually
going to have omar alta corey from the
think team
break down one of our most recent viral
videos and share with you the
ingredients
that should be inside of your next viral
video my name is heather torres
and you're actually here on the think
marketing
show and we are going to be jumping into
that but i just wanted to say if you're
new here to this channel
make sure you subscribe so you get
notified every single time
a new video comes out well we're going
to be jumping into the main content
today
and this is actually coming from our
youtube strategy
workshop here at think every single year
we love to put together
a solid two to four hours of time with
our current members of our video ranking
academy
the uh number one place to learn how to
do youtube right
and we really dive into what you should
be focused on for
this year and one of those sessions was
brought to you by omar eltakori the
lead content creator here at think and
he broke down the five ingredients
needed for a viral video by sharing just
a case study
of what we're doing here at think and i
will hope you have your notepad ready i
want you to lean into this and before we
get into it i just want to let you know
that we have a new web class up so if
you have not taken
our current think master class i want to
let you know that today's
video is brought to you by
thethinkmasterclass.com this is where i
think media
we go deeper into teaching you the three
secrets to success
on youtube and how you can actually jump
in
to getting started right on youtube how
to connect the dots when it comes to
creating your channel
hacking the algorithm understanding how
to get views and how to make videos
that will help the people on your
mission well we're going to jump into
the featured content today
and then after that i'll come back on
for a little bit of q a so let's jump
into
omar's training case study of
a recent viral video on think media and
just break it down and how we actually
came to this and the reality is it was
the number one
um viewed video of 2021 as far as what
was uploaded
and then talk about the ingredients
which i've put together in five
various teas uh because i like
literation
it helps you remember but let me just
tell you uh
real quick what happened was in on
october 14th
uh just last year a couple months ago we
uploaded and posted a video
um i was on a zoom call with the think
team we we meet
uh three times a week on zoom you know i
was on my laptop
and you know laptops just have the
lamest uh webcams ever not only is the
quality just trash
but like it shoots up at your nose and
then you just get the follicles and the
hairs
and all that stuff and you don't want
that happening right and so i thought i
was like how can i get my laptop kind of
like
the camera up to my eye level and i
found that like
there has to be a way to use your phone
as a webcam and then uh
sure enough that's what i searched you
know and i looked and i'll talk about
through this process but that is the
video we
sir uh that we uploaded on this day it
is called
how to use your smartphone as a webcam
wanted to
you know see how better uh your webcam
could be
rather than using the one that's built
in and and it's using the phone that you
already have and
you probably guess you're like whoa
there's so much going on why is omar's
eyes that big
why is there you know all this stuff
we're gonna talk about all these things
that made up this video but the biggest
thing is that
in just this short amount of time it's
gone over a quarter million views this
is
way above what we are typically doing on
our daily uploads
um and there's something to say about
why this video was
the most successful video upload that we
had on think media
in 2021 uh and so i'm gonna i'm gonna
show you the back end analytics and
literally show you uh like live and show
you all the things that happened
with this video and things that we've
learned from it but before we do that
i have a huge confession to make i i
just i got to take the time
um to make this confession confession
i absolutely love coffee
it's it's like a weird kind of love
though like you're probably like man i
omar i love coffee too
no let me tell you how much i love
coffee right now
this is my coffee setup here in the ltac
rory
household you got your batch brew on the
left
that allows me to brew up to 10 cups of
coffee i have my bur grinder because you
want to grind your beans
with a single pass so you can achieve
the most consistency
of your grind size and and then to the
right you have a breville
dual boiler espresso machine allowing me
to pull the shot with a commercial size
group head
and uh steam milk at the very same time
to achieve
the optimal optim optimal temperature
when brewing uh espresso brace espresso
based drink this is my coffee setup i am
weird
but i love it i literally go to sleep
every night i'm like i'm excited
because tomorrow i'm gonna get me some
coffee and so when you think about the
the reality of coffee essentially it's
this it's it's coffee and water
uh and then uh put together with a
certain amount of
um you know ratios and things like that
and i would say out of all the
the gear you see right here probably one
of the most important
is this scale uh the the way to get the
best cup of coffee
it takes having in a dialed recipe and
um
and and with that recipe comes the the
right rate ratio from cot from water to
coffee
uh you want the the right temperature of
water 190 to 200 degrees of water
uh and and when using the espresso
machine you need a certain
degree of pressure to go with that
coffee all
this works together to create a great
cup of coffee
and i have a great cup of coffee every
day but
that's the same idea as what it takes
when it comes to making
your next breakout or viral video you
need the right ingredients and so
we're going to be talking about the five
ingredients to include
in your next viral video
um and i've broken it down into five t's
and so this is the recipe for virality
it is
number one uh topic number two
is tutorial three is title
next is time and the next is thumbnail
and these
all will work together for the good of
your
video views um and so i really hope that
this
write these five down i'm gonna break it
down in just a second um
but pumped about this uh breaking this
down so here we go
the first thing is uh finding the trendy
topic
of your video um this is one of the
worst things that typically happens uh
when people have a breakout video that
wasn't
ex planned or expected is now they have
a
a breakout video in something they don't
know
or want to be known about right like
you know like my breakout video was a it
was a video
on me create you know using your phone
to create use as a webcam
which lines up with what we're doing at
think media so i'm all about it let me
be the webcam guy
and let me be the guy that levels up
your live streams you know like but if
if we made a random video and that went
viral that wouldn't do much and it
wouldn't make sense so
all that to say you want your viral
video to align with your channel's niche
this this is very important because you
don't want to be famous for the wrong
thing you don't want to climb
the wrong mountain uh but nonetheless
you want what you're
what you want to be known for to get big
right and then number two
is ask yourself what is a current
problem or trend
uh with the with the world or in the
industry that you are a part of
what is a current trend or or what's
happening in the world and
um you know uh that leads you to help
you determine then
the type of video you should be making
because uh when you are able to speak
into the the topic that you have
identified and what you're going to talk
about
then you're going to create a tutorial
around that topic
so because this reality this is a
psychological reality that when you
teach people or when you show people how
to do something
you become an authority they
automatically deem you in a higher
position because you are now teaching
them
every time we were in the class like if
the teacher told you to be quiet you
were quiet because
they're giving the information and it's
time to be quiet but there's something
psychologically
about that that when we uh are are
learning from somebody
we are slowly placing them in a higher
place psychologically
in regards to the information that they
are giving number two
essentially you're going to just create
a how-to video that requires no money
you know tony talked about you know the
various viral or the various tips that
you can do to create
um titles on for your next few videos
that how to is so important and it was
so important this year in 20 or in the
previous year in 2020 that
how many things that you search because
now it was like a new year and we were
all doing new things um all that to say
uh if you were celebrating new year's
there was an awesome commercial
and youtube actually made this
commercial and i want to play it right
now
um just to kind of prove a point uh when
it comes to
creating these tutorials and on trendy
topics and so
let's run that video hey youtube
how's it going i am fine feeling lonely
i still don't know how to cope
i found comfort how to
get through 2020 without losing your
[Music]
sanity
got to keep them hands fresh maintain
social distancing show you how to make a
super easy
mask
[Music]
you are courageous and brave
[Music]
we have to stay strong it's okay to let
it go it's okay to cry
i'm doing the best that i can i do
believe this too shall pass i know it
will
this is tough guys i'm dizzy everything
earth
we're going to learn how to iron a dress
shirt
this is how i am teaching remotely
[Music]
today's your big day are you excited
mama
is tired six feet apart
you have to feed your creativity build
this tree house
you guys ready for the movie see what we
can do
[Music]
i'm so excited
[Music]
you're going to make it to the other
side of it and that's really all that's
important
man if that video if heather's session
didn't make you cry and if that video
didn't make you cry
you got some issues now i'm just kidding
man how how powerful was that video
like but what omar what's the point why
did we even why did you even play that
that if you put the right topic at the
right time uh
in the right time of the the year that
you can literally break through
that how many people broke through in
youtube because
people were searching how to do stuff
honestly on think media
our channel exploded in april june
because people are like how do you start
a youtube channel what gear should we
buy but we've created searchable
videos around the topic and niche that
we are part of and it lined up with with
what was going on specifically in the
video that i was talk
that i'm sharing in this uh training is
is
people are using their webcam people are
you know people are now working from
home and so
it was using that this reminds me of a
specific word that we've
essentially never heard before before
2020 and that was this word it was
stimulus check i don't know i haven't
heard about that word
prior to 2020 but when when that was the
news and that was the big talk
i tell you what these finance channels
and even some real estate
channels started hopping on this keyword
and started talking about stimulus check
and
specifically there were three people
that
really blew up last year because they
just
went with the trend and the topic and
they started creating tutorials and
talked about these things
and the first person on the left is meet
kevin this guy's a
investor real estate guy but he started
putting out videos on the stimulus
and boom it like started flowing like
crazy this next uh
person in the middle is erica kohlberg
uh
her channel two blew up and now she has
uh
like around 50 60 000 subscribers uh
the next one you see is clear value tax
this guy has been posting for a couple
years but when he started talking about
um the stimulus check his stuff blew up
and i
that all that to say there's just you
gotta know your your tren
the trends you are speaking into you got
to know the times that you're speaking
into and creating these videos
and um all that to say when you've taken
all this information
uh now you can make better better videos
and here's how you can do that this is
how you can make better videos
number one is you you start landing on
your title
you start landing on your title start
this is just a simple practical way i
know
tony uh talked about a lot of other ways
to achieve your title
but one way too and he mentioned this on
his last breakout
was just start typing it in in the
youtube search bar this takes no
special websites no special anything
just youtube
start typing in this is what i did i
started typing in how to use your phone
spacebar
and look what showed up as a webcam that
was the first thing that showed up and
honestly uh vra fam
we go super deep with trainings like
this inside of the facebook group
when it comes to keyword research and
things this is like the basic of the
basic but it's a vra fan that really
really gets that
dialed in getting the the right words to
use for your titles
and so this is just the baseline this
everybody
in this training right now can do this
go to youtube start putting it in
and so yes i saw the phone as a webcam
and then when i hit search
you know this is so important this is
this could serve as a power tip
um when you search the video that you
want to make you're
you're doing it for two reasons you're
doing it to see
the competition uh no ultimately but
you're you're doing it to see the times
of videos in order to that achieve that
tutorial so
i'm looking and i'm seeing like how long
is it taking for other people to
teach this exact title how to use your
because if i can make it shorter if i
can make it better than i am right
uh the same thing is to compare your
thumbnails and so going a little bit
deeper
a lot of people ask us how long should
our videos be
like how long should maybe your next
viral video be this is what we teach at
think media
as long as necessary and as short as
possible
be bright be brief be light be fun and
be done
and and that's huge and so i call this
the shorter effect when you
search on uh youtube and you see the
competition
of the video that you are about to post
or create or
record then you now have the data that
hey i need to make this video shorter
because how many times have you searched
for something on youtube and you simply
selected the shorter tutorial because we
none of us have all that time anymore
right i mean we do but we
that's just how we live our attention
spans are quicker and so
you typically click on the shortest uh
video and so
that's something you need to take into
account in your next viral video make it
shorter
than the competition you know uh also
the next thing is the better effect um
when when it comes to developing your
thumbnail
and your video but specifically your
thumbnail now you can look at all the
thumbnails that people are doing and
just make yours better
and better doesn't mean more busy better
just means simple
stand out with simplicity i love how
heather talked about kiss
keep it simple and also keep it
short simple and short are your best
friends in 2021
i'll tell you that much and so
essentially this was like what i was
working with this is
everything that showed up first page
when you search um
you know how to use your phone as a
webcam and i saw that a lot were pretty
busy and at the same time
all of them are crazy too so like i was
trying to find a way you know to stand
out and that's why i'm going to talk
about how we
came up with the thumbnail that we
actually went with
but make your video shorter make your
thumbnail a bit better
but the process we actually landed on
this thumbnail because
um clicking on a thumbnail
is huge because it's the one that
attracts your eye right the one that you
click
and so like uh like tony mentioned
earlier with coming up with three titles
i would encourage you to come up with
two or three different thumbnails
options are your best friend um so when
it comes to
um developing your thumbnail having
about a few to work with
is where you want to start and then the
next uh
thing about that is you want to get
feedback like
so this is actually a post on slack this
is our slack thread we have a full team
of people that we can bounce ideas from
vra uh there's they share thumbnails
with one another and they get feedback
on their thumbnails i would encourage
you to maybe in this workshop find
somebody that you could
feed your thumbnails off of i have a few
friends in my life that text me hey
this one or that one it's just it's
great to get some feedback when it comes
to
your thumbnails and your titles but
nonetheless
maybe uh this is it's important have a
few options
to uh choose prior to going with the
thumbnail
the next uh so we this is what we ended
up kind of essentially starting and
landing on
uh the big thing was like why don't you
look up at the phone and and then so it
points attention to
the phone as you see i'm pointing and my
eyes are looking at the phone
but there was an issue and so the next
step was the phone's getting lost on
that black wall
and so let's we swapped it out for a
white one these are just little things
that we're doing to help
communicate what this video is about but
ultimately to get that click
because if it was if if this was just a
laptop that's not that's no fun but now
you see a laptop and you see a phone
you're like oh man
i have a phone and i have a laptop and
uh speaking to that
reality too um people also using zoom
and stuff and so this is
this is what people are seeing every day
and so kind of think through the mind of
the person
always have that creator in mind when
making it this is the funny
thing that happened and i think i i mean
this could literally be the
sole reason why this video broke through
is because
they gave me etis and i say they because
i worked up to the
the thumbnail up to this point and then
nolan on the team was like bro we should
just like
make you look like e.t so it just looks
weird i'm like
man whatever if this is the sword i
gotta die on let's do it
um so we made my eyes bigger and the
reality is
when you have big eyes in your in in a
picture or in a video
with the reality it not don't do your
video with this effect by the way
but um is that people pay more attention
tubefilter.com did a study revealing
that
uh close up on faces preferably making
eye contact
humans have evolved to detect eye
contact
so making thumbnails with eye contact
more eye-catching especially
if the whites of the eyes are visible
like not your
anything else don't squint or anything
but in addition to this human
communicate in large part by reading
emotional cues in the face
so i'm not looking directly at you but i
am you can see where my eyes are looking
right and so it's pointing your
attention
and then the next thing to relate to
everybody else was just to add the zoom
logo because this is why
people are doing they're they're working
from home and they're doing zoom and so
that's how we landed on this thumbnail
the thumbnail is so important but just
notice how there was a process
to land on the perfect thumbnail for
this video
and then um as far as uh
like the the analytics of this whole
thing um let me just show you real quick
how this all worked out and so on on the
analytics side of things
you can see that um we uploaded this
video on october 4
14th right and then you could see it
kind of just grow and grow and grow
and let me tell you this if if there's
one thing you need to practice this year
it's gonna be patience because when you
can do all that you can do
uh when it comes to titling your video
thumbnail your video
uh do all those things that you can
control all the things that i talked
about
that then youtube can suck you into the
algorithm which is all what we want we
want to
get sucked into the algorithm algorithm
but this video didn't pop off until
almost a month after it dropped a month
went by and then it was just
boom and you can see these are all views
that are hap that are compiling
compound views on this video and so
it's just taken off but don't think that
just because in the first week of your
upload
that you know your video is not going to
work if you've done what you can hands
off the wheel
and let it do its thing this is what's
so cool about youtube being a search
engine
and that youtube then uh prioritizes
your videos in in ways that you can't
now now the number one way it's it's
suggested so when people are looking at
like
things like other videos similar to this
youtube is now suggesting this video
second is uh youtube search that's the
goal
is that now this video is working uh and
it's
gained us 2 000 a little over 2 000
subscribers
made a almost a 900 bucks it's getting 6
400 views every two days
don't you want a video that has 6 400
views every two days um
you can do this friend and it like viral
like sean mentioned
viral doesn't mean millions viral is
when you're of you have a breakout video
in your niche and it makes sense with
what you want to talk about and be known
for
and so 250 or 260 000 views in a couple
months is awesome uh for what we teach
and what we do
um and so that's some of the um that is
some of the
uh the the behind the scenes when it
comes to the analytics
on youtube and so uh more than anything
that
this is just a short power session i
wanted to just share that case study of
of this specific video and how we you
know got with the times and we knew what
was happening people were working from
home
you know we created a tutorial around
that that costs
no money so i'm taking you from a to b
uh with no money needed
developing my title then we uh having a
short video that
in comparison to the competition and
then lastly landing on your thumbnail
to really have that full awesome recipe
for virality and
cooking the the best video that you're
gonna post in 2021
and ultimately i think the biggest thing
is is to um
is to really just do that we always say
like base hits you know like
you know maybe a product review here and
then maybe a tutorial here and there
but like sometimes they can turn into
home runs and and and
you're one viral video away from really
breaking through in your industry
and for people that deem you as the
authority in what you are teaching
well that was a piece of our youtube
strategy workshop thank you so much
omar alta corey for uh coming in and
helping us
learn how to make viral videos um one
thing that i
took away from that session that omar
said really was the idea
that it's a process and so i really want
you to to be thinking about that when
you're creating youtube videos and
you know when we were having that
strategy workshop i remember one of the
comments was like man all this seems
really hard
right like this all looks like it takes
time and i just want to encourage you
that as you're creating youtube videos
as you're growing your online business
around your youtube channel
that this is going to be hard and it is
going to take time because good things
will like these types of things don't
just happen overnight and you have to
work hard to make these things work
so i just want to encourage you that if
you're just getting started on youtube
if you are in the season where you just
feel like you're in a dip like you feel
like you're just not getting the
traction
that it may be time for you to take the
youtube class we have a free youtube
class here at think media
and i want to encourage you that your
next step might be to go and register
for our free class where you're gonna
learn
what's working on youtube and why it's
important to actually know
these uh different analytics that matter
but not only that
how to make the right videos for your
audience because i know that if you're
here
watching this video that you're a
purpose-driven content creator that you
have a message that you want to get out
and that you just need to figure out
what videos should you be making to be
able to get views and earn money and be
able to create a lifestyle that works
for you and so
i want to encourage you that your next
step might be to go and watch our free
youtube class this class is coming down
soon and so i don't want you to miss
this opportunity and then at the end of
that class
you'll be given the opportunity to join
us inside
of video ranking academy that's one
thing that omar
did say inside of this is that you know
our vra fam i saw
a hashtag in the comments our vra fam
really is where our heart and soul
is here at think we are there helping
that community
and so if that is the right option for
you then you'll actually get this entire
youtube
workshop for free when you join video
ranking academy so that was just one
little piece of the entire workshop so
uh go ahead and register at
thinkmasterclass.com for that free class
and
if you want to check out another video
just like this you can tap or
you can tap the screen and go to the
next video and until then i'll see you
soon bye